後輩からカントリーマアム250校もらいましたありがとうみなさんを育つどう過ごし
でしょうか
肇社長です僕がめちゃくちゃ楽しく過ごさせていただいております
昨日も朝まで久しぶりに友達ともう死ぬほど遊戯王カードがしたりしてて夕日に過ごさ
せていただいております今日はちょっとあのこれだけは生はもうでもう休もうかと思っ
てたくらいなんだけど
これだけ話したいというお話があるのでちょっと話させてください
1月1日襲うガス早々にやらかしてしまった
お話ですこれあのホントにマジで久しぶりにもうううううああいやう
って安全にやらかすたって思ったことです
まさかの2017年1月1日の夜に起こると僕よく行く悠遊カードのお店があるんです
けども
その悠遊カードのお店っていうのはその遊戯王カードでバックとかねカード1枚とかで
こういろんな売り方があるんですけどもぅを試せる
月8月みたいのがあって1回300円なんですけど
なぜたチャを回すとかぶせでが1個出てきます本とガチャガチャのカプセルがポンと出
てくるんですけれども
その中にシーン所 b 賞英四郎
へ首相の4つ性がありますでは普通でもねなんか今やっても c 賞 c 賞 c 賞
ですでもう新書し基本的に出ないんですけど新ショーなども普通に弱いカード10万円
くらいセットのはず
それで敏捷だとちょっといい間ぐらいからちょっと言い方300円400円500円
ぐらいのいいかあってええええ症になるともう年か後1000円か2000円ぐらい前
にであたりのカードが出て
首相はもう出たと媚びたことなかった安倍首相はもうなんか
1枚2.5へのカードが中鎖8枚セット
一応
1いくかいかないかぐらいが s 賞であるんですよそのよっての性が入ってるんです
けど僕たまによく回すんですよ来ませんですけど本当にどうぞ針に詠唱が出たりまあ何
回かマーサーたまに b 賞が出てうれしいなぁみたいな基本的にはもう c 賞
ばったりで結構あたりにくいんですよ1回貯めればガチャ月は朴さんのそう月の夜に
後輩2人と僕の3人
そのカーショップに行きました後輩2人とか僕てね後年いろんなカードを買ったりして
空ってこんなかやってたんですけどやっぱお正月じゃないですか
あ
初までもうちょっと人が透けなくなったら一人で行ってきますっていう話じゃない1月
1日だったから今度が運試しみたいな事がしたくなったわけですよねちょっと運試しし
たいのってそのいつもやってる300円遊戯王カード方がちゃんのところへ行ったら
一人の
男性がいましたただ僕よねちょっととする位ぐらいの方々が僕よりちょっと年上くらい
の方が
10気を月朝が生活やってて本当にあの皆さんが想像している
ガチャガチャのたぶん3倍くらいやってます脱赤津はをもうなんかヤバいくらい300
いればくって言ってて立つ相方の麻酔の上のほうにね
てきたカプセルがすごい置いちゃったんですよパットに僕数えるとこれ多分30個以上
各種あったんで一番いいじゃんの人はガチャガチャやってますその1何を狙っているか
というとまあ間違いなく裂傷出せば早いタイミングで s 賞を出せば多分 s
show 1万円くらいのカツはあるんで
10体あってせ書を出せば3000円1万円が当たったと同じで七星の得になるわけ
です
その人は多分その300円でめちゃくちゃガチャガチャ回して頑張って s 賞を出し
て行為ジェンを迎えたかったわけですよ多分あって木刀後輩がそのが生活のところに
行った時もその人めっちゃガチャガチャして多分37回分発日目ぐらいのところでやっ
てたと思います
[音楽]
その人はそこでやり続けるべきだったのかもしれない
僕と後輩2人で狡猾朝のところに行って家なんか運試しがてら回しちゃうみたいな感じ
でちょっと話してたら
ソフト多分いい人だったんですよいい人で金配ってくれてなんかぐっかつ騙してるん
ですけど
100円玉ないなぁちょっと了解といってこよーみたいな感じでちょっと省察を出し
ながら両書の方に行ってなぜか他の場所を開けてくれたんですよだがそのガチャ方の中
もう30何回もあったら中身が超少ないわけで厳選されているわけでそれでもその人は
回し続けているつまりまだ英首相が出ていない状態で僕たちにカチャカチャおゆず
入ってしまったその中待ってる人がいたらさんの譲ってくれる生主の本当に素晴らしい
と僕も思います本当に良い人でした
いい人でしたでまずはまあ先輩の僕が the まず俺から打ったメッシュでマーシャ
あってその人が彼の量買いに行った気に相手なので僕が1回まわしました
ガシャーン a 所
波動したあー
これを出すために回せたんじゃないのかやらかしたその人が続けて混ぜたら影響が出て
なんですけどたまたま譲ってくれた僕に詠唱のパンが回ってきちゃってエースを奪っ
ちゃったんですよ
ブーブー僕はもう迷うことなく欲しかった詠唱の超高級カード
そこそこ高いカードブレークを奪ってカードをが300円でゲットしてしまいました
ああああああ
旅やいっ
いい年になりそうでしただけがここで話は終わらなかった残り後輩2人がいるわけじゃ
ないですか
で僕に続いてその2人も並んじゃってても量がいいせいかその38回場所た人は
ちょっと後ろに並んでたわけですよで目ですよ
源さんおめでとうございますじゃあ僕も回しまーすってちょっと気の弱そうな僕の後輩
が客インナー3つしか言わなかったらしくて僕
もうちょっと1回まわしてみますみたいな感じでこう1回まわしました
行っちゃった婚 s 所
もうんって呼び申す受けなかったその後編1回しか回せないからもう300円で1万円
ゲットしたようなもんなんですよ
9,700円の特もうその人もすごいなら優しそうな人だったんですけど僕の後輩は
sc を出した瞬間もう顔が
ってなってたんですよもう誰も悪くない
誰も悪くないんですよだか結局タイミングなんですよそう
タイミングなんでたぶん何も当たってなかったんだともよさんの感じでその人は38
買いでしょ
13000円くらいかかったんだもうほんとねあの本当にそのエッグもんねーねー老け
たず杉田気まずい気持ちだ
に向こう38小針小のカクテル持って鼻血頭にしてるわけですよ
普通だったらめちゃくちゃ喜ぶとこなんですけどもうその前に12000円分まわして
た人がいたんですっ
k 山化したなって思いましたという感じですねちょっと1月1日からすごい人を
悲しませてしまいましてはじめ社長です
でも世の中
タイミングだぜ沢山飾らせました方を見ていたらここでお詫び申し上げます本当に次の
前でした
me
ええええええ
[音楽]
バッハ